now i want to start off by saying i
always believed in thomas cruz when
everyone else doubted him because he was
a scientologist and he was in love with
katie holmes i said he's still a damn
good actor and look at what everyone's
saying
edge of tomorrow the original title of
this film was all you need is kill it
should have been called all you need
is tom cruise
oh everyone shut up i'm trying to do a
show here everyone shut up i'm gonna
make a bold statement right now i'm
gonna italicize this statement and then
underline it
microsoft word jokes this film is the
[ __ ] not a pile of [ __ ] it is the
[ __ ] a possible contender for what might
be my favorite movie of the year now i
know a lot of you guys are going to be
like what about x-men days of future
past raid 2 spider-man godzilla all that
crap you know what i'm gonna have my
opinion so back off although x-men days
of future past might be better okay i
want to start by talking about this film
by first talking about my favorite thing
thomas cruz he plays the
main character i forgot the character's
name cruz is fantastic in this role one
thing that trailers don't show you is
that this guy's a total wet [ __ ] at the
beginning of this movie like he
illegally gets drafted into this future
alien war aliens equaling mexicans he
fights a lot of mexicans in this movie
it's tom cruise versus a bunch of
mexicans that's not the plot of the
movie no they're like real
extraterrestrial beings that like
that's my impression of that because
she's in there flipping around the whole
time it's crazy [ __ ] but cruz he's a
coward at first and what's great about
it is we never see tom cruise play a
[ __ ] and he's great at playing a [ __ ]
which is ironic because he gets a lot of
[ __ ]
some think he just gets caught but i
think he gets [ __ ] like when he's
afraid hey you totally get it and you
feel it you buy it the whole time what's
cool is they have like this groundhog
day kind of plot where he keeps
repeating the same day over and over
again and each time he improves in the
battlefield and he gets more badass as
it progresses everything about this
movie is fluid everything complements
one another this movie is just synergy
at its best like to talk about cruz's
character you gotta talk about the
action as well now this is not non-stop
action yes it is action-packed but
there's a real story going on over here
but what's cool about the action is that
each scene gets cooler than the next
each scene just gets more stylistic it
just gets more badass because tom
cruise's character is getting better and
better so it's complementing itself
really in [ __ ] stuff don't get me
wrong though like tom cruise he's
believable as his underdog like as he's
going on this journey you're like yeah
you you go futuristic rocky balboa meets
bill murray emily blunt
blunt
there's a wee joke here somewhere i
don't remember a character's name i just
remember they called her full metal
[ __ ] she's [ __ ] awesome it's like
she's not even acting like she doesn't
try in this movie she's horrible and
that's what i mean i mean that it's like
so believable that you don't even think
you're watching any performance she's
the toughest [ __ ] around same time
she's [ __ ] beautiful and her and tom
cruise have amazing chemistry together i
hope they were banging on sex but
seriously their chemistry together it's
not like a romantic chemistry or
something but it is a big reason why you
should watch this film the story is
great i love the whole like groundhog
day meets oblivion type of movie it's
all captured beautifully by director
doug lemon the film yes it's intense
it's a spectacle it's action-packed but
there's a lot of heart in it you really
give a [ __ ] about these people how's
that what's going on like what surprised
me the most was that this movie had me
laughing an awful lot not because there
was unintentional laughs like the laughs
they were intended to make you laugh
some might say it was an intentional
laughter like tears some of those jokes
thomas cruz
sorry i smoked some family blood earlier
and this film is paced like incredibly
well too for a story on this type of
caliber where it keeps repeating the
same day over and over again it's hard
to make a movie like that feel like
fresh throughout the whole time and feel
entertaining throughout and it manages
to do just that like the weird thing is
the story
is about repeating but the film
doesn't feel like it's on repeat
wow but each time like the day restarts
which is like 300 000 times sometimes in
like the funniest ways the story
progresses the characters advance the
action intensifies and speaking of the
action the visual effects and production
design
whoa dude it was like one of the coolest
sci-fi worlds i've ever seen it looked
like it was from a graphic novel and yes
i know it's based on a graphic novel ha
i fit in with the cool crowd out there
honestly when a movie is this good and
this original i don't want to talk too
much about it i just want to tell you
guys just go [ __ ] watch it already
because everything even the score is
fantastic
just so
this is a moving picture just know this
the writing directing acting
cinematography editing production design
visual effects action and of course the
music are all [ __ ] exceptional every
single thing in this movie was different
and always entertained which leads me
into this
no wait a minute let me get
straight to the point here because it
was pointing this way this was not
straight
got it all in all i gotta say edge of
tomorrow got a super duper [ __ ]
ryan the right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for edge of tomorrow watch go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell me if you can repeat the same day
over and over again how many chicks do
you think you could make
in one day
i give myself a maximum of two i want to
throw out there you can follow me on
twitter deal rio ryan right follow the
real rejects on twitter facebook
instagram fine all that [ __ ] plug into
our social networks this is what they
call promotion
jerry
don't you [ __ ] forget it last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews or videos is out
going to click on this button on my dick
to subscribe
that's right
the ticket
limited something about this little tom
cruise
every time he [ __ ] a girl
he can [ __ ] them
almost until the edge of tomorrow
and then
she dies not because of a
sexual assault battery case she
they die but then they live again
and then they repeat it
i should have stopped this joke at edge
of tomorrow